- [Mark] All right, Elizabeth.
Elizabeth, you grew up in Tulsa,
you just told me?
- [Elizabeth] Yeah, Tulsa, Oklahoma.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents growing up?
- [Elizabeth] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- [Elizabeth] How was your what?
- Childhood, okay, very well.
Something like "Little
House on the Prairie".
I don't know.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah, it was something like that.
- [Mark] That's nice.
- Back then.
- [Mark] And you grew
up with other siblings?
- Yeah, Katie,
Lizzie and Stacy and Tracey.
That's all, as far as I remember.
- [Mark] You left home at what age?
- Oh, about 18.
- [Mark] After high school?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And where'd you go?
- Oh, just went on and went
to school or something.
You know Calhoun high
school, further past that.
- [Mark] Oh, in California?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you guys moved to California?
- Yeah, but I never went to college.
No, not yet.
Didn't want to do that.
- [Mark] Did you have
kids? Do you have children?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] How many kids?
- Six kids.
- [Mark] Six kids?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you raised them?
- Yeah, they're all fine.
They're beautiful.
And they're healthy and they're happy.
They never complained
and never complained or anything.
And that's the way they were.
- [Mark] You're living on the street here
in downtown LA.
- This is the city of Los An- yeah.
- [Mark] And did you live in a tent
or where are you staying?
- Oh, wherever.
With friends and family
and things like that.
And then I go over there
and then I make a living
and clean up or do jobs.
- [Mark] How do you make money?
- Odd jobs or something and,
vacuum and clean these kinds of things
and just wasn't sure what it was.
Good lessons to pass.
And things like that
are good for your brain.
Jogging and exercise every day
but when I wake up in the morning
the main thing is I look the same.
You're ever out there, you know.
- [Mark] Do you still have-
- My aunt probably
put that when she was
a nurse or something.
'Cause she looks like that.
She had beautiful eyes.
- [Mark] Do you still have
contact with your kids?
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah, they're fine.
They're fine.
- [Mark] You talk to them?
- They're with Jose, my husband.
Sure, yeah.
When I see them, yeah.
I don't have no problems with that.
That's just the way they were born.
- [Mark] Do you have a phone?
- Yeah, in Rancho Cucamonga and in Shea-
- [Mark] No, but do you have a cell phone
to call your children?
- A cell phone?
- [Mark] Do you have a
phone to call your children?
- Just the one they
handed me back over there,
where I was at.
But no and that's okay.
That's fine.
Yeah, just the little,
the different ones
that I didn't know how to work them
'cause I wasn't sure what-
- [Mark] Do your kids know-
- But I learned how real quick.
- [Mark] Do your kids know
that you're here on the street?
- Yeah, they know I'm a good mother.
My kids were a little bit smarter than me.
Fell through again, like a turtle.
But why do I say that?
Oh, I don't know.
I saw a turtle in Riverside
or something there,
but it was more a "Poltergeist".
That's a nice movie.
- [Mark] Do you have any problems
living on the street?
- [Elizabeth] No, no.
- [Mark] Nobody hassles you?
- Nope and nobody,
no bad-mouthing nobody,
and nobody gave me harassment
not even to gossip.
- [Mark] They leave you alone?
- [Elizabeth] They don't
even use words like that.
Like Hackenberg, a school teacher.
He was a New York school
teacher, you know?
'Bout that big, yeah.
He was from Jay high school.
The brown book where you study history.
Yeah, that's how I made my skin.
My body's like-
- [Mark] Do you use any
of the drugs that are out here?
- [Elizabeth] No, maybe
some of the kill-pains.
Sure, yeah.
Anybody would.
But I was never obnoxious with it.
- [Mark] No alcohol or drugs?
- [Elizabeth] No.
Well, in Las Vegas you
couldn't help yourself to that,
but I never took advantage of that,
'cause I couldn't.
But they couldn't even
get it if they tried,
and they were trying
to get that out in the open.
Take it out on some, but you know,
some people like that.
But not for me.
- [Mark] How many years have
you lived on the street?
- [Mark] Oh, since I
been here in Los Angeles.
Well, probably like,
two plus one,
three years I've been here now.
I think.
Yeah, the shelter.
- [Mark] What were you doing before that?
- [Elizabeth] Oh nothing,
just married and had kids.
And then I worked at restaurants.
I had a good job.
And no, I didn't make very much money,
but that was enough to learn.
- [Mark] What happened to you
that you ended up homeless?
- Oh, just the way it was
just lucky like that, probably.
My family was like that in the past.
I couldn't figure out
how they did that, so.
And that's why Pandora, she always,
my cousin, she was always,
faster than me.
I was too slow.
She couldn't take it no more.
She takes it out on me, you know?
That's the way it was in the past.
- [Mark] And do you
have parents still, or?
- Yeah, they're still happy.
KW and Ken,
that's what I called them.
When I saw a picture of them though,
the other day in Los Angeles.
They were wondering where
they'd been all these years.
Oh, well they live in Jay, Oklahoma.
You know, somewhere out in the country,
that's where they live.
I didn't choose that for them.
That was their favorite
place to be but I didn't-
- [Mark] When's the last time
you spoke to your family?
- Oh, Jay.
Oh gosh.
I'm not sure what year that was.
Cause I've been sleeping.
I sleep a lot, a daily thing,
but I always wake up and look at the,
but when's the last time I talked
to my parents and Jay?
Oh, let's see.
She moved down there,
so it'd be
about 10 years ago,
something like that.
- [Mark] And where do you eat?
- Oh, just whatever my mother,
the eggs.
I eat bread and butter
- [Mark] I mean
where do you eat now?
- Oh, where do I eat now?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- The shelter mostly with
my friends and family.
We're all mixed in, yeah, together.
- [Mark] Do you have any
friends here on the streets?
- Well, not strangers, no.
No, not that I know of.
I thought of others.
But I didn't, never.
No, never ever.
I always go back to people
that were good to me
because that's just the way it is.
I remember when I was in school,
I graduate 12th grade
at Central High School in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
My friend,
he was a real nice friend,
he'd sit by me or this
and that or whatever.
I couldn't remember exactly
what he was thinking,
but he was right about a lot of things,
she is something out there.
But yeah, it is nice in Los Angeles
because they bring back
the happy things, you know?
- [Mark] But what was the happiest
point of your life?
- Oh, getting a high school diploma.
And five times I got that.
Eighth grade in San
Bernardino High School.
And then I find another
this and that school,
high school plus the other
school in Los Angeles.
I didn't know that was there.
I was so surprised, I couldn't believe it.
And it was so lucky to have school anyways
because they were so into that.
- [Mark] Elizabeth, have
you ever been treated
for any mental conditions
or anything like that?
- Yeah, schizophrenia with Dr. Schlechter.
I like him.
Yeah, I do.
I already had that answered in my body
and I didn't know what to
do with and he knows it.
- [Mark] And do you take
the medications for that?
- Yeah. I take a lot of 'em.
Especially when it's looking right at you
and you know-
- [Mark] Are you taking them now?
- No, just a little bit of pills I take.
but I never take
OD on anything
because I'm not like that.
You can't make somebody
be what you want to be.
- [Mark] But living on the street,
I'm guessing that maybe
you're not taking your medications?
- Oh yeah.
Yeah, I take some pills.
Pain or things that control your mind,
just like exercise every day.
But if you don't want
to eat or you're full,
then you'll get skinny again.
It all depends upon how you look at it
when you saw your arms and lap.
But I don't know what the hell for.
I never-
- [Mark] All right, Elizabeth.
- I never thought of that.
- [Mark] Well, Elizabeth.
Thank you for talking with me.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] And I wish you the best
of luck living on the street like this.
- Yeah, that is something.
- [Mark] It seems like you should
probably be taken care
of somehow, in some way.
- Yeah, I'm just looking at myself.
Isn't that something?
The body.
I think that dirt could be,
- [Mark] When's the last time
you took a shower?
- I didn't say dirt, huh?
- [Mark] When's the last
time you took a shower?
- Oh, when my mascara.
Oh, when I took a shower?
- [Mark] When was the last
time you took a shower?
- Oh, over there by 7-Eleven.
Yeah, that's the place I take a shower.
Over on sixth street.
They had showers.
The cold one-
- [Mark] But when's the
last time you took one?
- Oh, about two or three days ago.
(Elizabeth sniffing)
Yeah, I'm fine, I smell beautiful.
But I always find these beautiful things.
I couldn't believe it how nice it was.
I was thinking,
my God, who gave me all these things?
I didn't even know that.
Didn't know it.
- [Mark] All right, Elizabeth.
- That's what I thought you said.
- [Mark] Thank you for talking with me.
- Okay.